j'ouvre notre second thème vous savez il
est volontairement décalé de l'actualité
du jour on prend du recul pour analyser
la visite de Xi Jinping à Vladimir
Poutine la semaine dernière à Moscou on
va voir ce qu'il y a autour de cet axe
Chine Russie avec nos invités mais
d'abord retour en images sur ces 48
heures ou les deux présidents ont mis en
scène ce qu'ils appellent je cite une
nouvelle ère de leur relation spéciale
Samia de chien faire front face à
l'Occident 3 jours après l'émission d'un
mandat d'arrêt de la Cour pénale
internationale à son encontre Vladimir
Poutine a reçu la semaine dernière son
homologue chinois une visite festueuse
de 48 heures destiné à rompre
l'isolement international du dirigeant
russe mais aussi à afficher le
rapprochement de la Chine et de la
Russie dont les relations seraient
entrées dans une nouvelle ère
les deux déclarations communes que nous
venons de signer reflète pleinement la
nature particulière des relations russes
aux chinoises qui sont au plus haut
niveau de développement de l'histoire
dans cette déclaration commune aux
accents de guerre froide la Chine et la
Russie accusent les États-Unis de saper
la sécurité internationale alors que les
Occidentaux soutiennent l'Ukraine dans
le conflit qui l'oppose à la Russie la
Chine elle défendent officiellement une
feuille de route pour des négociations
de paix
je voudrais souligner que sur la
question de la crise ukrainienne la
Chine a toujours suivi les principes de
la Charte des Nations Unies défendant
une position objective et juste
promouvant activement les pour parler de
paix depuis
le long pour une rencontre avec Titine
réponse du président chinois qui a en
revanche déjà prévu d'accueillir
Vladimir Poutine en Chine à l'automne
jusqu'où ce soutien chinois à la Russie
peut-il aller la Chine peut-elle jouer
un rôle de médiateur dans la guerre en
Ukraine en débat avec Jean de gymnastie
bonsoir bienvenue vous êtes ancien
ambassadeur à Moscou entre 2009 et 2013
directeur de recherche a l'iris et
auteur de ce livre la Russie un nouvel
échiquier qui est publié aux éditions
Eyrolles j'accueille pierre asci bonsoir
bienvenue vous êtes chroniqueur
géopolitique pour France Inter et pour
l'Obs ancien correspondant en Chine et
réalisateur d'un documentaire qui est
diffusé ce soir à 23h sur Arte nous
sommes Taïwan Antoine van das bonsoir
bienvenue à vous aussi chercheur à la
Fondation pour la recherche stratégique
enseignant en sciences po auteur de
Pékin et le conflit ukrainien
opportunisme pragmatique qui est paru
dans le numéro d'automne 2022 de la
revue Politique internationale et puis
Mélisa baski évidemment est restée à mes
côtés on va commencer euh par cette
visite évidemment de de Jean Ping à
Moscou est-ce que vous diriez que
c'était surtout un message envoyé aux
Occidentaux finalement
en fait un peu tout le monde parce que
aux Occidentaux parce que c'est le front
antioxydantal je crois que c'est la
chose de base qui unit Poutine et ses
inping et puis au Russe aussi parce que
finalement quand on fait le bilan de la
visite il y a pas grand chose donc ça
veut dire on vous soutient mais
il y a une limite à ce soutien parce que
c'est frappant d'ailleurs dans la presse
russe il y a on sent à fleurer une sorte
de désillusion et blogueurs russes
prennent leur distance et montrent que
en fait l'attitude chinoise est en deçà
des attentes russes très clairement
pierre Aski moi j'ai relu en préparant
l'émission le communiqué final signé
évidemment par les deux présidents il y
avait des des fausses airs de guerre
froide de hier froide et il disait quand
même
prioritairement les États-Unis se
communiquent c'est le ciment de la
relation entre le Poutine et sitting
c'est effectivement de s'opposer aux
États-Unis et les deux ont une bonne
raison de le faire alors Poutine
évidemment parce que il accuse les
États-Unis d'être derrière la guerre en
Ukraine et d'être l'organisateur du
front anti-rus etc mais c'est typique
c'est très bien que que lui aussi est en
confrontation avec les États-Unis c'est
pas le même type de confrontation il y a
pas de de guerre militaire mais il y a
une guerre technologique qui est
déclarée et qui est très forte qui est
peut-être le front le plus sensible
entre les États-Unis et la Chine et il y
a tous les points de d'achoppement qui
sont à la question de Taïwan évidemment
la mère de Chine méridionale rien que la
semaine dernière vous avez
CNN a diffusé des images intéressantes
de d'un avion chinois qui est venu à
de espion américain qui survolait la
mère de Chine méridionale et l'équipe de
ciennet était à bord ils ont filmé le
visage du pilote tellement il était prêt
et voilà ce qui se passe à peu près tous
les jours
dans cette zone donc les États-Unis
c'est effectivement le point commun qui
les unit après je rejoins ce que ce qu'a
dit Jean c'est vrai que le le contenu
concret et et relativement décevant du
point de vue russe
rien sur les armes alors peut-être que
c'est resté dans les clauses secrètes en
n'en sais rien et a priori pour
l'instant la Chine n'a pas franchi le
Rubicon des livraisons d'armes à la
Russie pour pour l'aider dans sa guerre
d'Ukraine et Poutine a annoncé en plein
cœur de la visite qu'il y avait un
accord sur la construction d'un deuxième
gazoduc pour envoyer en Chine en gros le
gaz que n'achète plus les Européens et
puis c'est pas dans le cabinet final ça
ça on en reparlera du gazoduc mais je
voudrais d'abord vous donner il y a
quand même une sorte enfin le simple
fait que si j'ai une pink soit là
c'était déjà peut-être
une petite victoire pour en tout cas un
isolement diplomatique qui qui était
fissuré ou brisé il y avait déjà ça quoi
le message c'est la visite neuvième
déplacement de ping en Russie depuis fin
41e rencontre entre chez une ping et
Vladimir Poutine et les mises en scène
d'une proximité non seulement entre deux
pays mais surtout entre deux régimes
après je suis parfaitement d'accord le
soutien chinois il est pas
inconditionnel il y a un soutien depuis
le début de la guerre qui est politique
qui est diplomatique qui est économique
la Chine contribue à atténuer une partie
des sanctions occidentales il y a pas de
soutien militaire je pense qu'il y a pas
de soutien militaire et qu'il y en aura
pas en tout cas avec des livraisons
massives d'armes pour au moins trois
raisons voire trois plus une la première
c'est que ça détruirait tout le discours
chinois qui cherche à présenter la Chine
comme une puissance responsable
contrairement aux Américains qui eux
sont des fauteurs de troubles et qui
sème le chaos et ce message s'adresse à
la Chine aux chinois mais aussi au pays
d'un occidentaux deuxièmement la Chine
s'exposera des sanctions
occidentales massives contre certains
conglomérats de défense qui même s'ils
font du militaires font aussi du civil
avis le grand Comblain de défense
aéronautique fait aussi du civil et puis
troisièmement il y aurait surtout une
accélération du rapprochement
transatlantique l'Europe les États-Unis
qu'évidemment les Chinois essayent de
limiter et puis un tout dernier point si
la Chine entend jouer un rôle pas de
médiation mais en ton jouet un rôle à
terme un jour peut-être dans un an
peut-être dans un an et demi quand la
situation sera différente si elle est
livrée des armes ce sera quasiment
impossible de le faire donc la Chine n'a
aucun intérêt à en livrer elle en a pas
livré jusqu'à présent je pense qu'elle
le fera pas mais genre de clignaci je
parlais de l'isolement diplomatique de
la vie en Poutine il est il est réel
on peut pas parler vraiment d'isolement
diplomatique c'est plutôt une séparation
totale de ce que Poutine appelle
l'Occident collectif mais sinon les
briques se sont là les chemins comme la
dit Antoine mondaz le fait même de de
visiter Moscou alors deux jours après
que Poutine a été
disons montrer à l'international de
guerre
c'est un signe il y a la moitié du monde
qui est-ce qu'elle défie la Moscou vous
voyez ce que vous voyez ce que je veux
dire
Luna devait y aller puis il est tombé
malade donc et puis comme l'indice clair
que Moscou n'est pas isolé c'est tout
simplement l'application des sanctions
c'est sur ce point qui est fondamental
que la Chine même si son aide étant de
ça désespérance de Moscou apporte un
comment dirais-je c'est considérable
comme apport et les Chinois estiment que
c'est suffisant mais les Indiens la même
chose les Brésiliens aussi etc
d'économie vous l'avez évoqué piraski à
ce projet de gazoduc annoncé nouveau
gazeux contre les deux pays annoncés par
Vladimir Poutine on l'écoute
nous venons de discuter d'un bon projet
le nouveau gazoduc power of cyberia 2 à
travers la Mongolie presque tous les
paramètres de cet accord ont été
concertés il s'agit de 50 milliards de
mètres cubes de gaz provenant
d'approvisionnement fiable et stable de
Russie
et donc si vous nous disiez c'est pas
dans le communiqué final donc ça veut
dire quoi ça veut dire que c'est dans
les limbes en fait ce projet c'est non
je pense pas je pense ça signifie
surtout que les Chinois négocient
c'est-à-dire qu'on n'est pas dans un
automatisme où on va vous soutenir on va
construire un deuxième gazoduc et on va
vous acheter tout le gaz que vous avez
lorsque le premier gazoduc a été
construit ça a pris très longtemps pour
arriver à une négociation sur le prix
sur les conditions et etc et donc là on
est dans le même cas de figure c'est à
dire que on va vous acheter ce gaz parce
que c'est c'est sans doute du bon
business pour la Chine d'avoir ce
coffre-fort de gaz et de pétrole
à portée de la main mais visiblement
n'est pas tombé d'accord sur les
paramètres de du contrat et c'est ça en
dit long sur le fait que il y a la
politique
l'entente
est presque idéologique même si on est
plus dans cette
ère mais en tout cas antioxydantal et
puis de l'autre côté il y a la réalité
de de la vie des États qui ne sont pas
prêts à brader leurs intérêts et il faut
pas oublier mais c'est c'est souvent on
emploie le mot alliance à tort c'est pas
une alliance entre le la Russie et la
Chine c'est à une
partenariat stratégique très approfondie
et qui n'a cessé de s'approfondir depuis
que c'est une pique est arrivé au
pouvoir mais qui n'est pas une alliance
au sens classique du terme où on au
secours du partenaire s'il est s'il est
en difficulté c'est ça une alliance mais
qu'est-ce qu'il est
éloigne les uns des autres en quelque
sorte si on si vous dites c'est pas
c'est pas une alliance qu'est-ce qui
provoque les divergences ou il y a ce
qui les unit et puis il y a ce qui peut
aussi les laisser je pense que la Chine
n'a aucun intérêt de signer une alliance
avec la Russie et une convergence
d'intérêts politiques entre deux régimes
plus même peut-être qu'entre deux pays
il y a deux pays et surtout de régime
politique encore une fois qui considère
que leur sécurité politique la
préservation du modèle politique c'est
la priorité en matière de sécurité
nationale et à partir de là on voit un
rapprochement si nos russes mais c'est
pas pour ça qu'on a un alignement entre
les deux pays ils sont pas alliés donc
ils sont encore moins alignés on a une
asymétrie croissante qui crée des
opportunités pour la Chine à la démarche
de négociations qu'elle n'avait pas
auparavant et puis sur la question
pétrolière la Chine n'a aucun intérêt
est trop dépendant de la Russie elle
diversifie comme elle l'a toujours fait
et ce qui est intéressant dans la presse
chinoise aujourd'hui c'est la mention
d'un investissement saoudien
en Chine dans des raffineries et je
pense que si ça arrive aujourd'hui après
la visite en Russie c'est pas un hasard
le message qu'on voit les Chinois c'est
nous avons le choix on est sur un marché
international où on est les premiers
consommateurs de pétrole au monde on est
les premières en tout cas les premiers
acheteurs pardon de pétrole au monde on
diversifie on joue la compétition et on
a aucun intérêt à être dépendant des
Russes est-ce que je trouve intéressant
c'est cette reconfiguration en fait
géopolitique qui est en train de se
tramer la Russie avec la Chine l'Europe
avec les États-Unis elle est souvent
liée à des intérêts économiques en fait
que prévoit la Chine finalement elle
choisit ses alliances qui n'en sont pas
réellement parce que le fond c'est
plutôt l'économique qui gère soit
l'énergie soit j'ai des restrictions
vis-à-vis des États-Unis la Russie aussi
et du coup on va s'allier mais c'est
plus enfin on s'allier en tout cas
temporairement mais c'est plus sur un
plan économique et c'est ça qui est fou
parce que la Chine se positionne comme
ça en arbitre pas en arbitre en
médiateur pas en médiateur mais sur un
plan économique la plupart du temps
selon ses intérêts mais lorsque ce que
il faut bien comprendre c'est que ce à
quoi on assiste en ce moment c'est la
transformation de la Chine en
superpuissance et et une superpuissance
elle défend ses intérêts elle a ses
atouts et elle n'est pas dans le partage
ou la
bienfaitrice de l'humanité elle est en
train de devenir une superpuissance et
elle l'a montré c'est très intéressant
la dernière période mais le l'accord de
rétablissement des relations
diplomatiques entre l'Iran et l'Arabie
Saoudite qui s'est fait apk sous l'égide
de de la Chine entre ces inimaginable
c'est sans précédent ce qui s'est passé
et c'est vraiment le signe que la Chine
a passé un cap dans dans sa stature
internationale et dans en tout cas dans
ce qu'elle veut projeter comme image de
sa stature internationale et ça rejoint
ce que disait Antoine tout à l'heure sur
le fait que elle a pas intérêt à donner
des armes à la Russie parce que elle
veut être aujourd'hui elle s'adresse au
reste du monde elle s'adresse au Brésil
au sud-africain aux indonésiens et
interdit voilà nous sommes nous la
puissance responsable du 21e siècle la
puissance Pacifique responsable du 21e
siècle on va en reparler dans une toute
petite minute de ce partenariat
militaire et Quentin Canet mais je
jouais à vous entendre les uns les
autres je me dis mais si on regarde
finalement dans cette alliance qu'il en
est pas une je vous entends bien le
faible c'est Poutine ah mais c'est clair
c'est clair c'est ressenti par tout le
monde
c'est pas un choix économique
automatique la Chine en fait les russes
auraient préférés faire affaire avec
l'Europe
et ses contraint et forcé à cause des
sanctions qui se tournent vers la Chine
d'ailleurs la Chine avait commencé à
prendre la part européenne du marché des
importations russes bien avant la guerre
du crâne je me souviens quand je suis
arrivé en Russie
l'Allemagne avait
14% à peu près du marché des
importations russes maintenant les
descendu un peu plus de neuf et les
Chinois sont à 25 alors qu'à l'époque
ils étaient à 12 donc il y a un
phénomène économique écrasant et puis
les Russes sont pas totalement enchantés
non plus d'une chose c'est que il
voudrait que les les Chinois
investissent en Russie en fait ils
investissent très peu il est très
frappant de voir que les entreprises
européennes et occidentales qui ont
quitté le marché russe ne sont pas
remplacés sauf de rares exceptions alors
par exemple Renault mais Renault est
parti dans des conditions un peu
catastrophiques mais pour l'écrasante
majorité ce sont des intérêts russes à
défaut d'autres intérêts qui ont repris
les entreprises occidentales qui parlent
donc la Chine fait du commerce mais elle
n'investissent mais elle n'investit pas
c'est un signe aussi alors on va parler
de ce partenariat quand un calmez-vous
pouvez nous nous rejoindre tout de suite
rebonsoir Quentin et je vais reprendre
les termes que j'ai donné en lancement
du du sujet d'ouverture de ce second
débat quand il y a eu cette rencontre
entre Vladimir Poutine et exige INPI il
y a eu ces termes employés une nouvelle
ère de notre relation spéciale de quoi
parle et bien effectivement ce sont les
mots employés par les deux hommes mardi
dernier les deux présidents ont signé
une déclaration je cite sur
l'approfondissement du partenariat
stratégique journal Le Monde qui parle
de dirigeants qui ont mis en scène la
semaine dernière vous le voyez leur
coopération aux perspectives illimitées
ce sont là les mots de Vladimir Poutine
cette coopération initiée au début des
années 90 a connu une accélération avec
la guerre en Ukraine en fait la Russie
s'est tournée vers la Chine suite aux
sanctions occidentales le commerce entre
les deux pays à atteint un record en
2022 c'est 190 milliards de dollars
Thomas selon les douanes chinoises les
exportations russes ont augmenté de plus
46% en 2022 la Russie privée de
déboucher en Occident exporte vers la
Chine principalement des hydrocarbures
et cherche à importer des composants
électroniques alors on a commencé
l'évoquer qu'en est-il du partenariat
militaire alors depuis 2004 la Chine et
la aussi reconnaissent mutuellement et
officiellement leur frontières
respectives cela a été une étape
importante de leur rapprochement depuis
2014 deuxième étape on voit leur
relation militaire se développer avec
les livraisons d'armes de la Russie vers
la Chine on parle alors de sous-marin de
classe Kilo ou des systèmes de défense
entière aériennes depuis le début de la
guerre en Ukraine on a vu cette
coopération continuer notamment avec des
exercices militaires avec les deux pays
on va s'arrêter un instant sur ce point
septembre 2022 un contingent chinois a
participé aux exercices de vos stock
2022 c'est dans l'Extrême Orient russe
deuxième étape novembre 2022 les deux
pays qui ont envoyé des patrouilles
aériennes communes en mer du Japon et
enfin décembre 2022 vous le voyez ils
ont organisé des entraînements en mer de
Chine orientale alors il y a évidemment
la grande crainte notamment des
occidentaux que la livre des armes à la
Russie voilà depuis le début de la
guerre la Chine a évité l'envoi d'armes
ou tout implication militaire
notamment à cause de la pression
internationale venue principalement des
États-Unis la semaine dernière le site
américain politiqueo a écrit que des
entreprises chinoises dont une liée au
gouvernement de Pékin attend ont envoyé
aux entités russes mille fusils d'assaut
et d'autres équipes m'en pouvant être
utilisées à des fins militaires on parle
ici de petites cargaisons et également
d'équipements à double usage c'est à
dire des articles qui pourraient être
utilisés à titre civil mais aussi sur le
champ de bataille devant le Sénat
américain c'est la dernière étape le
secrétaire d'État américain s'est voulu
rassurant concernant la livraison
d'armes létale à la Russie à ce jour
nous ne les avons pas vu franchir cette
ligne c'est ce qu'a dit Anthony blinken
donc devant le cinéma c'était le 22 mars
dernier on écoute cet échange avec un
sénateur américain
sénateur j'ai fait part directement à
mon homologue chinois du graphe problème
que représenterait le fait de fournir un
soutien matériel létal à la Russie
pensez-vous que cela fonctionne
pensez-vous qu'ils vont fournir à ce
jour nous ne les avons pas franchir
cette ligne pour l'heure les experts
maintiennent que la Chine ne devrait pas
livrer de nouvelles armes à la Russie
par peur de possibles sanctions
occidentales la Chine cherche également
à apparaître comme stabilisateur auprès
de l'opinion internationale merci
beaucoup Quentin vous l'avez évoqué tout
à l'heure on doit demander à mais je
veux bien vous entendre là-dessus parce
que bon effectivement le le Rubicon de
la livraison d'armes a pas été à pas été
franchi mais alors c'est quoi ces mille
fusils d'assaut d'autres équipements
c'est rien du tout c'est
pas rien mais mille fusils
c'est anecdotique du côté chinois vous
êtes bien conscient que ça les
embarrasse plus qu'autre chose que je
pense que ces entreprises vont être
surveillées un tout petit peu plus côté
chinois et qu'ils n'ont pas intérêt à
donner une mauvaise image de la Chine
entre guillemets pour mille fusils
pareil quand Der Spiegel il y a trois
semaines annonce que peut-être qu'il y
aurait une livraison de 100 drone à la
Russie il faut réaliser ça n'a aucun
intérêt livrer Sandro avec les coûts
dont on a parlé en termes d'image en
termes de sanction en termes de
rapprochement transatlantique et autres
pour son drone qui ne changeront rien
sur le champ de vide il va y avoir des
livraisons d'armes ce serait pour enfin
si abîmer son image ce serait massif
mais sur ce pont moi je suis persuadé
que du point de vue chinois une défaite
militaire de la Russie et gérable un
affaiblissement économique de la Russie
et gérable un effondrement politique et
par contre beaucoup plus problématique
sauf qu'un une défaite russe militaire
ne signifie pas forcément un
effondrement politique en tout cas c'est
pas automatique même si on fait
généralement le lien et là dessus la
Chine est inquiète potentiellement d'un
effondrement politique priori on en est
pas là il y a pas de signe particulier
je suis pas spécial de la Russie mais là
dans ce cas là peut-être que la Chine
changerait de politique changerait de
position et pour l'instant le coût de
livrer ses armes et bien plus important
que le bénéfice de le faire et puis
pierre Aski il voulait un peu évoqué
mais il c'est une sorte de bataille pour
l'opinion mondiale aussi qui est en
train de se de se jouer oui c'est c'est
un peu la
conclusion à laquelle on arrive depuis
le début de ce conflit c'est que il y a
une partie du monde qui ne s'aligne pas
qui ne suit pas qui n'a pas envie de
prendre parti dans cette guerre et c'est
cette partie du monde là qui fait
aujourd'hui
l'objet de toutes les attentions on le
voit bien aussi bien de l'Europe des
États-Unis mais évidemment de la Russie
et de et de la Chine parce que on a eu à
la faveur de cette guerre on a vu
apparaître le phénomène de
l'émancipation de ces puissances
moyennes qui refusent de de s'aligner on
a beaucoup parlé du cas de l'Inde qui
évidemment et d'un côté contre la Chine
avec les États-Unis parce que elle a des
problèmes frontaliers et historiques
avec la Chine mais qui de l'autre côté a
augmenté ses importations de de pétrole
et de de gaz russe et qui
joue ce multi alignement comme on dit
plutôt que non alignement
vous avez évidemment le cas de l’arabie
Saoudite dont on parlait tout à l'heure
mais qui est très spectaculaire lorsque
Joe Biden est allé à Riyad pour demander
au saoudien d'augmenter leur quota de
production pétrolière pour faire baisser
le prix par rapport à ta crise de que
nous traversions les Saoudiens ont
refusé en disant on a un accord avec les
Russes au pep+ on touche pas à cet
accord et quelques semaines après si
timing avait le tapis rouge à Riad quand
on connaît l'histoire de l'alliance
entre la famille régnante en Arabie
Saoudite et le les États-Unis qui
remonte à la seconde guerre mondiale qui
est basée sur pétrole contre sécurité
qui a été un des piliers de la
diplomatie américaine au Moyen-Orient
c'est un retournement spectaculaire on
peut citer aussi l'Afrique du Sud pays
qui
dont on aurait pu attendre avec sa
démocratisation etc qui le qui soit du
côté du droit international ben il reçu
Sergueï lavrof il y a pas longtemps il y
a eu des manœuvres communes entre la
marine sud-africaine et les Marines
russes et chinoises dans l'océan Indien
et et l'Afrique du Sud par fidélité à
son héritage de la lutte anti-apartheid
qui était soutenu par les Soviétiques et
pas par les Occidentaux a choisi une
sorte de note de
neutralité bienveillante vis-à-vis de la
Russie c'est ce qui est c'est-à-dire un
refus de s'aligner sur les Occidentaux
donc c'est c'est là qu'il y a qui a une
bataille qui est en cours et que la
position chinoise elle doit être
énormément analysée à travers cette
grille là plus que par rapport à ce qui
se passe sur le terrain en Ukraine
paradoxalement on est là une semaine
après la visite de chili Pina à Moscou
et une semaine avant le la visite d'État
du président français a Pékin on va
parler de ça ensemble tout de suite
Émilie ça va se passer du 5 au 8 avril
prochain oui ça y est Macron le
médiateur alors à l'international
attention est de retour comme annoncé en
février donc le président sera en effet
du 5 au 8 avril avec l'objectif de
travailler avec son homologue chinois
dans le sens d'un retour de la paix en
Ukraine la France et l'Europe avait
beaucoup misé sur le rôle de la Chine
dans ce processus de paix avec le
document qui avait été publié le 24
février 2023 jour du triste anniversaire
du début de la guerre qui appelait
Moscou et qui a fasse engager dans un
processus de paix ça c'était le
président chinois à ne pas recourir à
l'arme nucléaire et à éviter à éviter
toute attaque contre les civils de quoi
espérer donc un engagement de la Chine
aux côtés des occidentaux pour ramener
un petit peu Poutine à la raison des
espoirs donc qui ont été vite touchés
par rapport à cette visite dont on
parlait de Xin Jin ping en Russie à
l'invitation de Vladimir Poutine une
visite qui a permis au président chinois
de mettre en avant tout ce dont vous
avez parlé l'amitié la coopération
illimitée l'amitié illimitée sous
conditions évidemment alors comment
Emmanuel Macron compte-t-il jouer le
médiateur alors il y a trois thèmes qui
sont envisagés pour cette visite d'État
les questions stratégiques et les crises
internationales évidemment la
coopération face aux grands défis
mondiaux et les relations économiques
parce que nous aussi on y pense
forcément à noter le président français
sera accompagné par la présidence de la
Commission européenne histoire de parler
d'une seule voix l'Union européenne sera
représentée d'une seule voie alors quel
est l'objectif de d'Emmanuel Macron
évidemment la diplomatie prend une part
très importante dans son dans son agenda
dans son calendrier forcément il y a une
utilité c'est aussi pour se donner une
posture internationale de premier plan
peut-être aussi pour s'éloigner des
conflits internes dans le contexte que
l'on connaît mais alors il parvient
parfois à des succès quand il est
diplomate comme le lancement du plan de
relance européen on se souvient au
moment de la crise covid mais il accuse
aussi des échecs il y a eu des
tentatives ratées de médiation notamment
entre l'Iran et les États-Unis alors à
l'époque c'était Trump qui était
Président c'était en 2019 c'était au
sujet du nucléaire iranien il y a eu
aussi des envolés de sauveteurs août
2020 au milieu de la foule à Beyrouth
alors que le Liban était en pleine crise
politique et économique et d'ailleurs
encore actuellement puisque ces paroles
n'ont pas été suivies de beaucoup
d'effets et sans parler de ces
déclarations hasardeuses en novembre
2021 il déclarait l'OTAN étant état de
mort cérébrale juste quelques mois avant
le début de la crise en Ukraine qui a
montré que finalement l'OTAN pouvait se
réveiller en tout cas de cette mort
cérébrale et puis il y a eu aussi ces
essais de dialogue et de persuasion
auprès de Vladimir Poutine qui ont été
mises en scène très fortement souvient
du documentaire qui avait été diffusé il
y a quelques mois et qui ont pas été non
plus d'une efficacité énorme alors on
espère que l'expérience accumulée de ce
président qui a déjà fait un quinquennat
je vois le nom de la tête mais on espère
quand même que au fil du temps il a un
peu d'expérience parce que l'enjeu est
de taille petite citation de Churchill
la diplomatie c'est l'art de dire aux
gens leur vérité mais sans les offenser
et on peut pas dire que c'est la
spécialité de notre
ça s'appelle un éditorial
il y a plusieurs thèmes et c'est ça ça
merci parce que ça ouvre un double
chapitre à la fois sur ce qu'on a appelé
peut-être à tort d'ailleurs le plan de
paix chinois et puis sur le ce que la
France peut ou pas peser
dans ce contexte je commence on
reviendra sur le plan de paix donc une
fois je mets des guillemets c'est quoi
l'objectif d'Emmanuel Macron piraty de
cette de ce voyage à Pékin en fait il y
a une grande peur européenne qui est de
se faire entraîner par la guerre froide
américaine et donc les Européens cherche
par tous les moyens une partie des
Européens d'ailleurs parce qu'il faut il
faut nuancer un petit peu cherche par
tous les moyens à préserver un espace
politique de dialogue entre l'Europe et
la Chine c'est très compliqué parce que
nous sommes effectivement les alliés des
États-Unis dans la guerre du crâne et
leur et une partie de l'Europe notamment
celle de l'Est tient d'abord et avant
tout à préserver ce lien avec les
États-Unis et il y a eu une sorte
d'inversion des rôles français étonnant
parce que les pays de l'Est étaient
pendant toute une période courtisée par
la Chine et jouer le jeu parce qu'il y
avait un intérêt économique il y avait
ce groupe qu'on appelait les 17 plus 1
donc 17 pays d'Europe à l'intérieur et à
l'extérieur de l'Union européenne et le
1 c'était la Chine tout ça c'est
effondré et aujourd'hui on a des pays
comme la Lituanie ou la République
tchèque qui sont le fer de lance contre
Pékin il y a en ce moment même la plus
grande délégation qui soit jamais allée
à Taïwan c'est une délégation de la
République tchèque conduite par la
Présidente je crois du Sénat donc c'est
assez spectaculaire se retournement et
les pays d'Europe de l'Ouest en
particulier la France et l'Allemagne
veulent préserver ce triptyque qui a été
défini en 2019 par la commission qui dit
finit la relation avec la Chine comme
étant de de
partenariats sur des sujets comme le
climat des sujets multilatéraux de
concurrence
économique ce qui est légitime et de
rivalité systémique les Chinois étaient
pas très contents de ce qualificatif
mais c'est un tripty qui permet de
garder des relations avec la Chine et
d'être vigilant sur les sujets sécurité
ou de concurrence des loyale c'est très
difficile de garder ce cap quand les
Américains eux
en rajoutent tous les jours dans leur
opposition à la Chine on a vu à quelques
jours la le l'audition du PDG de Tik Tok
le réseau social était devant le Congrès
américain a été bien Bousquet et qui
était mais c'était cinq heures de de
l'été sur le grill et l'Europe est en
décalage par rapport à ça elle ne veut
pas rentrer dans cette logique mais
c'est mais cette voix est très étroite
notamment sur Tik Tok sur l'accès de
l'État chinois aux données des
utilisateurs entre autres parce que on a
fait une mission à plusieurs on pourrait
parler de l'effet sur le cerveau sur le
cerveau des des jeunes et des
allocations Occident mais ça c'est pas
notre débat j'en oublie assis est-ce que
c'est pas une mission impossible
finalement parce que
de fait vu la situation depuis le début
de la l'invasion russes on est bien
obligé de choisir notre camp ne pas se
laisser entraîner dans la nouvelle
guerre froide j'entends ça mais est-ce
que c'est parce que c'est possible mais
il faut préparer le coup d'après c'est
clair que maintenant quand est claire
nous sommes les défenseurs de
l'intégrité de la souveraineté
territoriale de l'Ukraine mais on sait
très bien qu'il va y avoir une bataille
plus ou moins décisive en tout cas qui
sera décisive sur le point que l'un et
l'autre seront jusqu'au ils peuvent
aller quels sont qu'elles peuvent être
leurs espérances sur le plan militaire
et donc ça va être le moment du début
d'une éventuelle négociation et à ce
moment là c'est vrai que la France a
intérêt à se démarquer un petit peu et
se démarquer auprès de qui ben des
faiseurs de paix c'est-à-dire ceux qui
se présentent comme tel tout au moins
c'est à dire la Chine pourquoi pas
effectivement le Brésil les briques etc
donc on a on a une carte à jouer dans le
sud c'est traditionnel en diplomatie
française
j'avais commencé Mitterrand dialogue
Nord Sud etc donc il y a un moment une
fois que la bataille aura fixé que le
sort des armes aura été fixé à ce
moment-là il faut peut-être préparer le
coup d'après Antoine Bourdin une visite
d'État comme celle-là et évidemment
préparer longtemps en amont il y a quoi
il y a des thèmes qui sont dont Emmanuel
Macron ne pourra pas trop parler il y a
des comment ça se prépare vite comme
honnêtement dans les rencontres
bilatérales les chiens peuvent nous
surprendre par exemple en 2018 ou en
2019 c'était les Chinois qui avaient
parlé de du Tibet au cours de la
conférence de presse c'était pas Macron
qui avait amené le sujet donc il peut y
avoir des surprises il y a pas de sujets
entre guillemets tabou la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'on amène les sujets
je pense que cette visite c'est une
opportunité unique et en même temps
c'est extrêmement risqué il faut
démontrer l'unité européenne c'est bien
pour ça que vendeur live on y va sans
pour autant montrer des divergences non
seulement transatlantiques mais plus
largement avec les pays affaires avec le
Japon avec le Canada avec l'Australie et
tout le monde nous attend en tournant
deuxièmement sur la question de la
médiation potentielle de la Chine l'idée
d'aller en Chine pour faire pression sur
la Chine pour qu'elle fasse pression sur
la Russie je pense que c'est illusoire
par contre il y a une carte
c'est c'est ce qui ressort en premier
quand on lit les communiquer les
articles etc c'est ce qui ressort en
premier alors j'y vais pour ça une chose
nouvelle de plus ce week-end et là non
par la Russie n'a déploiement d'armes
nucléaire en Biélorussie et
potentiellement d'un accord nucléaire de
partage nucléaire là il y a une carte où
la France peut à la fois se démarquer
des autres jouer son rang
et en même temps être utile c'est
confronter la Chine à cette question là
la France est une puissance nucléaire
elle n'a pas l'accord de partage
nucléaire contrairement aux États-Unis
et au Royaume-Uni dans le cadre de
l'OTAN et de mettre face la mettre la
Chine face à sa responsabilités en
demandant la position chinoise toute
façon que la Chine a toujours critiqué
le déploiement d'armes à l'étranger
toujours critiqué le principe même du
partage nucléaire et que depuis l'année
dernière elle présente même le partage
nucléaire américain comme une forme de
prolifération déstabilisatrice et bien
là il faut la mettre face à ces
contradictions lui demander sa position
lorsque la Russie fait la même chose
quelle est la position de la Chine et ça
il y a honnêtement aujourd'hui que la
France qui peut avoir la légitimité et
le poids politique pour le demander
alors si on reprend le calendrier
effectivement c'est assez passionnant
parce qu'il y a quelques jours avant la
visite ping on l'a évoqué à Moscou il y
a la Cour pénale internationale qui
lance un mandat d'arrêt bon et le jour
de l'arrivée du président chinois en
Russie on a Anthony blinken qui réagit
en disant ceci le fait que le président
chinois sidjin ping se rendent en Russie
quelques jours après que la Cour pénale
internationale a lancé un mandat d'arrêt
à l'encontre du président Poutine
suggère que la Chine ne se sent pas
obligée de demander des comptes au
Kremlin pour les atrocités commises en
Ukraine et qu'au lieu de les condamner
elle préfère fournir une couverture
diplomatique à la Russie pour qu'elle
continue à commettre ces mêmes crimes
Jean de gynastie est-ce que est-ce que
vous reprenez ces termes une sorte de
couverture diplomatique c'est la
première partie de la question et est-ce
que Vladimir Poutine oserait annoncer ce
qu'il a annoncé sur la l'accord avec la
Biélorussie sans cette couverture
diplomatique
écoutez je crois que pour la Chine
c'est très clair que la Cour pénale
internationale je sais même pas si elle
a signé l'Amérique la paratifié mais
elle a signé mais la Chine je crois la
même pas signé donc la Russie il a pas
signé l'Ukraine ne l'a pas signé donc
pour les Chinois très clairement c'est
un gadget occidental donc nul et le
navet et donc je sais même pas
s'ils ont pensé que Poutine avait besoin
de le raide dans ce domaine parce que
quand il considère d'ailleurs que c'est
le dernier clou dans le cas dans le
cercueil de la Cour pénale
internationale que de même dans la
bataille de l'opinion dont on parlait
pierre à ce qui tout à l'heure ça
qu'ils ont perdu l'opinion occidentale
et donc la bataille d'opinion c'est une
bataille de l'opinion occidentale pour
le sud de la bataille d'opinion je pense
que la Chine la presque gagné
internationale effectivement
sur le pardon je reprends la deuxième
partie de la question sur est-ce que
finalement la le soutien même si j'ai
bien entendu ce que vous dit il était
peut-être mesurer mais la somme présence
du président chinois Moscou quand même
ça avait un sens symbolique est-ce que
vous voulez dire Poutine se je vais être
un peu trivial mais ce sont poussés des
ailes vous voyez est-ce que il ose faire
ce qu'il fait après parce qu'il y a eu
la visite chinoise ou alors pas du tout
il suit son calendrier et puis voilà je
crois qu'il suit son calendrier sur ce
plan ça fait partie d'une règle du jeu
implicite entre ces deux puissances
chacun ils sont associés dans des
limites la la Russie reçoit cette cette
soutien symbolique est très important de
la Chine et puis ensuite elle elle
fonctionne en fonction de ses intérêts
j'ai été frappé par la modération
d'ailleurs de la position chinoise ça
fait très longtemps que les Chinois
disent qu'ils ne veulent pas
effectivement de d'installation de base
nucléaire dans les autres pays que ça
s'apparente à de la dissémination
nucléaire etc là ils ont dit oui la
Chine rappelle sa position enfin je
parle sous le contrôle de rappelle sa
position
en contre le l'extension du des bases
nucléaires à l'extérieur et en faveur et
contre la menace nucléaire donc en fait
dans le dans les 12 propositions
chinoises il y a une ambiguïté sur la
notion de souveraineté d'intégrité
territoriale et ça ça c'est très clair
dans la description de du plan de paix
d'accord et dans on ne sait jamais quand
les Chinois parlent d'intégrité de soins
des territoriales s'il parle de l'URSS
dans son ensemble aussi parle de la
République fédérative de Russie il y a
une ambition
il y a une ambiguïté qui fait qu'ils
peuvent se permettre beaucoup de choses
c'est plutôt une arme de communication
moi je suis très mal à l'aise quand on
parle de plan de paix les Chinois le
présentent comme un papier de position
c'est-à-dire eux-mêmes n'emploie pas
cette position chinoise non pas sur la
guerre en Ukraine sur le conflit en
Ukraine le choix Sém qui est important
c'est d'où ce point ils sont très connus
en réalité c'est les points qui ont été
présentés par la Chine alors un moment
c'était cinq points c'était quatre
points puis maintenant il y en a 12 on a
une rappel des grands principes
internationaux sur lequel tout le monde
est d'accord dire que l'humanité c'est
bien dire que la Charte de l'ONU c'est
bien dire que le respect de la
souveraineté de l'intérêt des
territoires et c'est bien tout ira un
discours de Miss France le frère c'est
tous les sous-entendus quand on critique
la mentalité de guerre froide quand on
critique la politisation de lait
d'humanitaire quand on critique les
armes biologiques alors on me dit mais
qu'est-ce que ça vient faire là tout ça
c'est des critiques explicites des
États-Unis pourquoi parce qu'il y a une
petite musique chinoise de
désinformation pour sous-entendre qu'en
fait les Américains avaient des
laboratoires d'armes biologiques en
Ukraine et que d'ailleurs en fait le
covid potentiellement pourrait venir des
laboratoires militaires américains donc
en fait il faut vraiment lire ces deux
points comme des principes généraux
comme une critique explicite de des
États-Unis et comme une façon pour la
Chine en de communication auprès de sa
population et auprès des pays
non-occidentaux parce que c'est ça le
nerf de guerre c'est pas de nous
convaincre qui s'en foutent pour parler
vulgairement de convaincre les Européens
ce qu'ils veulent c'est avoir une bonne
image au Brésil en Arabie Saoudite en
Inde en Indonésie en Arabie Saoudite et
surtout de dire à ces pays nous sommes
un partenaire important peut-être
nouveau mais on est un partenaire
important et maintenant nous avons un
poids politique qui nous permet de
débloquer des choses que nous pouvions
pas faire avant et juste rapidement sur
Iran rabbit Saoudite ça fait 20 ans que
la Chine fait de la médiation elle a
fait de la médiation dans les années
2000 entre le Soudan au Soudan
depuis 2002 elle a un envoyé spécial au
Moyen-Orient en 2017 à la coille apk des
pourparler Israël Palestine pour
l'instant ça marchait peu Soudan un
petit peu là non pas il y a c'est pas un
tournant c'est le fruit de 20 années où
la Chine à investi et où la combinaison
de son expérience et de son poids
désormais fait que ça se débloque juste
en miroir j'ai l'impression que depuis
des années on perd de l'influence que ça
soit la France ou l'Europe on voit en
Afrique là on voit qu'on n'est pas on a
du mal à agir en tant que Français tout
seul en tant qu'Européen pas beaucoup
plus au milieu de des États-Unis de la
Russie et de la Chine est-ce que est-ce
que c'est ces crises peuvent nous
justement nous réveiller un peu
là-dessus comme ça réveillait l'OTAN
est-ce que ça peut nous réveiller pour
reconquérir ça parce que la France
l'Europe avant avait cette influence
même au niveau de la langue même au
niveau de sa parole et on a perdu tout
ça est-ce qu'un jour on arrive à
rattraper ou cette géopolitique
réorganisée on est perdu là dedans
soyons clairs aussi il y a une partie de
cette affaiblissement qui est de notre
faute oui tout à fait
de commémorer il y a quelques jours le
20e anniversaire de l'invasion de l'Irak
par les États-Unis on ne on a oublié
parce qu'on l'a pas vécu dans notre cher
et en plus on a eu la chance de ne pas
participer à cette à cette guerre ce qui
était la décision la plus sage à cette
époque mais les dégâts
durables profond de cette guerre ont été
colossaux nous on a participé on a même
initié la guerre de Libye là encore on
peut pas comprendre ce qui se passe au
Sahel si on comprend pas la chute de
Kadhafi et donc on a aujourd'hui des
nouvelles générations et des pays qui
ont émergé et qui nous renvoient le
miroir de ce que nous avons fait si et
ça c'est quand même aussi c'est pas que
nous nous sommes endormis ou que nous
avons laissé le monde de changer c'est
que nous n'avons pas tiré les leçons de
de notre propre activité prenez un
dernier exemple pardon
au Moyen-Orient on vous dit
d'accord vous voulez faire respecter le
droit international des résolutions de
l'ONU etc mais dans le cas de d'Israël
de la Palestine qu'est-ce que vous avez
fait les résolutions de l'ONU on s'est
assis dessus depuis 7 décennie et on
voit aujourd'hui le la crise que vis
Israël et qui est qui est absolument
passionnante parce qu'elle pose des
questions de fond
tout ça c'est ce sont des je pense que
on est dans un moment de bascule du
monde dans lequel tout ça est mis à plat
et on doit pas simplement se dire oh là
là les Chinois ou les Russes sont sont
les méchants ils sont en train de monter
je pense qu'il faut aussi qu'on
réfléchisse à notre posture
internationale à vous le mot de la
conclusion oui petite nuance par rapport
à ce que dit Pierre c'est vrai sauf qu'à
l'époque en 2003 la France avait une
image particulière très forte très
puissante en Afrique c'était incroyable
les gens en fait étaient fiers d'être
copains de la France à l'époque parce
que la France avait une position
spécifique
particulière indépendante avec toute la
culture Voltaire tout ça les droits de
l'homme tout ça ça s'articulait dans une
position diplomatique spécifique à
l'époque à l'époque merci encore à tous
d'avoir participé à ce débat je vais
rappeler alors les titres de vos livres
Jean de Lignac si la Russie un nouvel
échiquier qui est donc publié aux
éditions
Hérolles pierre il y a votre
documentaire nous sommes Taïwan qui est
diffusé ce mardi soir 23h chez nos
confrères d'Arte et puis on donne Boda
il y a eu votre article Pékin et le
conflit craignant opportunisme
pragmatique dans le numéro automne 2022
de la revue Politique internationale
merci encore
à tous d'avoir participé à ce débat qui
était passionnant merci Émilie à très
bientôt sur ce plateau je vous donne
rendez-vous demain pour un nouveau
numéro de sens public et puis sur notre
antenne le prochain invité politique
c'est dans la matinale Oriane Mancini
qui reçoit Francky est sert le ministre
délégué chargé des relations avec le
Parlement belle soirée à toutes et à
tous